l'ajout de 30 nouvelles circonscriptions
il y en a maintenant 338 ça change la
donne et qui dit nouvelle carte
électorale dit aussi nouveaux noms pour
ces circonscriptions des noms qui croyez
moi peuvent parfois devenir un vrai
casse tête pour les électeurs comme nous
l'expliquent raphaël bouvier au clair
quand vous allez voter il ya deux choses
importantes desquels il faut se rappeler
le nom des candidats qui se présentent
mais aussi celui de la circonscription
dans laquelle vous vivez et ça c'est pas
nécessairement évident de s'en souvenir
il faut dire que depuis la dernière
élection il ya eu un redécoupage de la
carte électorale avec la création
parfois de nouvelles circonscriptions la
redéfinition de certaines frontières
aussi donc de nouveaux noms y en a qui
sont très courts et très simple celui de
delta dans ceux de la colombie
britannique en est un exemple et on a
d'autres qui sont beaucoup plus longs
celui par exemple de west vancouver
sunshine coast sea to sky country un nom
compliqué pour les électeurs de la
circonscription est avérée dans mon nez
jeunechamp gauche vous voyez que c'est
pas facile mais si les longs ce nom
c'est kim contient les régions de la
circonscription il ya la ville de west
vancouver plus à l'ouest
gala contre sunshine et enfin entre la
région de vancouver et celle de whistler
dans les montagnes il y a le corridor
sea to sky et des noms long basé sur la
géographie il y en a plusieurs par
exemple celui de rimouski neigette
témiscouata les basques au québec mais
ce que nous disait le membre d'une des
commissions responsable du redécoupage
de la carte électorale en 2012 c'est que
certains citoyens voulaient des notions
géographique dans les noms et on en
vient à la géographie
il ya beaucoup de communautés qui
veulent être représentés et des
sensibilités locales qui sont
extrêmement fin et le point notre rôle
de bousculer un nom quand il est long
plus en tout cas représenter un défi
pour les candidats par exemple sur
twitter où les messages ne peuvent pas
excéder 140 caractères mais aussi sur
les pancartes électorales par exemple
dans west vancouver sunshine coast sea
to sky country parmi les candidats des
grands partis il n'ya que celui du parti
vert qui a décidé un esprit au complet
le nom de la circonscription sur ses
pancartes